congratulations i thought you did a
great job with your feature debut um
it is a very ambitious project to take
something like this on for your first
movie
at any point were you like this might
this might be too much for me
for my first movie um
yes of course there were times where i
thought are you crazy
you know as when we were prepping for
the madison square garden
huge concert you know sequence where she
sings respect i was kind of like if you
get this wrong this may be the end of
your career
dummy you know like i was just like what
was i thinking but at the same time
i was so in love with every part of the
the film from the script to the casting
to getting to work on that music
that you know i knew that i was in the
right place doing the right exact right
movie that i should be making
it was intimidating though i i can't
even imagine
um i am obsessed with the editing room
because it is ultimately the final
rewrite and where the movie gets put
together
what did you uh i guess talk a little
bit about what was the biggest challenge
for you when you got in the editing room
to to put this thing together well
steve the the fact is i was in the
editing room with all my fabulous
you know um music editors editors you
know
yeah all of them for seven days and then
we
hit lockdown and everybody had to
retreat to their apartments and so i
edited this entire movie
during lockdown in new york city sitting
in my apartment
it was not how i would
what i would recommend for your editing
process for your first feature film
um it was tough and especially with you
know for a music movie you want to be in
the room with your music editor and your
your team feel if they're vibing feel if
they're if you know there's an
emotional impact happening and doing it
alone in
my apartment was really hard uh
it doesn't show with the movie so
congrats
uh did you have a much longer first cut
is this a movie that has a lot of
deleted scenes
yeah it does
it does i mean i i think our first
assemblage was maybe five hours long
i think i shot two movies in one
okay that's i don't usually hear that
number but that's like
a move that's a number that's like an
assembly cut that is just literally
everything
but what was there what was your cut
that you were like
oh this is pretty good what did you have
like a three hour cut that you're like i
don't know how we're gonna get this down
i had a three and a half hour cut that
was the first like these are all the
pieces
you know that that that
you know could could be seen um and then
we had to get it down
it had to you know of course it had to
come down and there were some painful
cuts that we made really painful like
entire numbers that i never
imagined i would cut did you end up
cutting those out before they were done
and like finished and everything or was
it one of these things that you
you know whatever i finished them i
finished them they were complete
so is it is it the kind of thing that
you have thought about
or talked with the studio about for the
eventual blu-ray
can we do an extended cut where i'm
putting back these numbers
i mean i definitely feel like those
numbers will
will have to get seen because there's
there's some pretty amazing things
um you know one of them was
jennifer singing dr feelgood and another
one
is i know another one is the uh skye the
the
young aretha singing her face off in
this beautiful
number called jesus be offense which is
this which is kind of what made aretha
little aretha famous in real life as a
gospel singer so
i was gonna say i have to go already i'm
just gonna say that i do hope i get to
see this footage
and please talk to the studio about
doing a at least showing these things on
the blu-ray
i certainly will i'm i appreciate your
uh your interest
i'll i'll convey that
i'm sure fans would love it uh hey
listen congrats on the movie i know
you'll be doing something again uh
very soon another feature for sure thank
you so much for your time
thank you steve